this is something that my wife and I did
do because we have a four month old
child and my wife sold her breast milk
some juice oh hell yeah
bought to some bodybuilders is that
legal maybe California no you can but
like did she make good money it was like
the same as like a gallon of homogenized
matter how much money no no I don't
think you ask what come on II I think
it's what you just accept that they
needed the money and they did charge
more if someone says hey man I'm a big
fan of theof on how much for your used
underwear you're like get out of here
gross yeah gross man and then they like
how about 500 grand you like yeah I get
you couple pair and that's how I'm
thinking about like breast milk is like
here I am being judgey yeah then when I
hear the amount I'm gonna go it was it
was more than a gallon of milk Wow and
so people what they ate ice was that
what you weren't sending more than a
gallon of know that would take a while
know the price the price is your wife
yeah yeah to hydrated now how do you are
when they get that what do you put it in
like a little bag or say yeah there's a
there's a bag there because my wife
would also donate breast milk to do some
hospitals to wear it like so like Mad
Max yeah sure pulling that milk out the
lady right there yeah I've never had
actually I had a little I think a girl
put some on mouth want this but this is
at a restaurant dude this is like close
in there
this is after the restaurant to close
okay was still in there okay what did
you like did you like get it from the
source that you like squirt across the
room or from the source Tucson Tucson
day a lady was in there an acquittal put
a little person in the ng
Miss bobbye's got no mirrors she's
cutting hair
you got worse hair at a restaurant a
family dining establishment gave you
breast milk from the sores put a little
on her finger but what are these men
doing with that Brad when they got they
were bodybuilders and so breast milk
allegedly has like a higher protein Oh
some BOTS so like some bought some
bodybuilders really like to have breast
milk so I've got some friends that are
in that community and and once they
found out to let you by we get some I'm
like sure but hey for ya I'm gonna give
you my baby I think I'm squeezing my
wife out over here yeah exactly
look at this here it says right here
body mothers are making thousands of
dollars selling their pumped breast milk
online of body builders some body
builders claim breast milk helps build
muscle mass more than any other food I
could see that you know did you about
making money that you feel weird about
uh
breast milk is actually much lower in
protein than cow's milk and bodybuilders
pacifically large men need much more
protein oh so they're wrong is a short
actually that shows like the protein in
breast milk compared to other milk yeah
but it was a nice little it was a nice
little side hustle oh yeah so I got I
got a goldendoodle right I just got him
he's like oh now yeah great dog and
every time there's been times people go
you're gonna get him neutered and I said
yeah I'm not yet he's only six months
haven't even dropped and then one lady
she goes oh you're not gonna neuter him
are you and how's it going one of these
people right mmm and so I was like well
I mean I don't know probably haven't
thought about it she's like well you
know it's good money has it one and she
goes oh well like what you can do is you
can there's like a stud fee we're
basically like if you want your dog to
have sex you'll like Adele someone will
take your dog for a few hours bring them
back your dog is you just get to have
sex and then they come back and hand you
a check for a pretty good amount Wow
yeah okay what happens yeah that's great
watching my don't need sex anyways I'm
not gonna watch but like they they want
to take him off my hands full in a while
he can go do that they said give me a
thousand bucks and then my dog comes
back all happy and tired I think that's
a pretty good deal and you got a fat G
yeah it's not like a goldendoodle girl
is gonna show up on our doorstep like
you know my father lives here right yeah
we need some child support like it seems
like a totally avoiding it scratching at
the bottom of the door you know here it
says right here in one cup of breast
milk yeah you have 20 you have 2.5 grams
2.5 grams if that's not much protein
not yeah cuz cow's milk has 12 grams is
that comparing it you see the other
there eight grams in cow's milk ol eight
grams and one percent eight grams and
skim yes so it's less so it has the same
amount as like almond milk virtually all
right well there you go just not even
milk it's just nut water yeah they go
bodybuilding yeah almond milk is just
nut water I know is getting milk
they should call it nut water they
really should because they they soak the
almonds in water nut juice or nut milk
I mean nut water I mean that they should
have like a rogue god almond milk
company and that's they would do to like
separate themselves like said milk out
there and where do you drop that off in
person do you leave that at the door how
do they go for the breast milk
bodybuilders yeah we dropped it off in
person
wow wow I love that good I like making
it yeah he's in there pumping out by my
urine I'd be like sure I'll get you as
much as you want you just keeping her
hide where do you keep buying her
Gatorades every other 7-eleven yes it's
like hair man hairs free man yeah it was
great because yeah there's never a good
time to go through a pandemic but like
we got the baby at home so it's like and
thankfully my wife and you know the baby
breastfeed so it's like that's a
renewable food source it's like I I
didn't have to go out and buy baby food
or anything like that we just had food
for the baby it was great and good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one